so whether you're planning a staycation
or a getaway this summer if you're
taking your pets you
always have to plan ahead and pet
trendologist charlotte reed is here with
her beautiful dog hammy
good morning charlotte how are you good
morning so glad to be with you guys
it's so good to see you again happy
summer hey this is so important
we want to start first charlotte with
sunscreen is there a sunscreen for pets
we can use
there are sunscreens for pets and this
is actually my favorite it's called
epipen sunscreen
it's got a 30 spf and what i love about
it is it's developed by a veterinarian
and it's made for pets actually dogs and
only horses no cats
what's great about this sunscreen is it
is a special bottle it's a valve lock
bottle so you can turn the bottle upside
down
and spray it so this way you know you
have a big dog
it's a lot of work to get under the
carriage so this way you can just take
epihat
spray it right under the carriage and
all over the dog with ease
and it's waterproof who doesn't love
that speaking of that what's
do you know an easy way to hydrate pets
because it's like
some of them love the water but some of
them just don't seem to drink enough of
it
well you know water water water is
really really important because dogs in
the summer they sweat a lot but they
don't sweat like us they sweat through
their paws
so just like us they're losing fluids
from their systems
so one of the things i like to do is i
like to take
like travel balls with me wherever i go
so if i'm just running around town and
the dogs with me
i have a small little single serving
size and if i'm traveling
let's say to visit you guys i need a
diner what i love about these bowls is
they fold up just like this
every summer so many dogs drown from
water accidents
sometimes it's at the hot you know your
house at the pool what can we do to
protect pets
well you know i'm glad that you brought
that up because a lot of people don't
know this but the rock
actually lost to his french bulldogs to
drowning they fell in his pool
so it's always a good idea if you're
near any body of water to have a
flotation coat a float coat or a life
jacket for your pet you want to make
sure you buy one that
is his size get him used to wearing it
before the first time you take them on
the boat the kayak or the canoe
you want to also make sure it's got a
handle so that you can lift him out of
the water
it should be bright colored so you can
see if there's low lighting conditions
bodhi my dog has been living and
breathing in the sprinkler in the
backyard
the past few weeks has just been so hot
but a lot of people especially when they
move to the desert here they're you know
they wonder how can you walk the dog how
can you keep them cool
when it's 114 degrees outside do you
have any tips for that
you are the best time to walk your dog
is early in the morning
and later in the evening what i suggest
you do for exercises
take them for outside to go pee or poop
but then do a little activity inside i
mean you can't replace the great
outdoors but when it's like 114 degrees
in las vegas you really can't take your
pet on that
asphalt and if you do just take him out
if you're living in an apartment
you might have to put some like
appropriate sav on his paws so they
don't burn
you know you might want to wet him down
a little bit like you said your dog is
out in the sprinklers that's how he's
getting some exercise
so the ground is wet but really make
sure you could
mist him down if you have to make sure
you protect his feet that might even
mean
wearing boots if you have to charlotte
reed is so great to see you thanks for
all the good tips and give hammy a hug
for us
we will say bye to alex bye
thanks charlotte